I was going everybody today we're gonna
talk about scalars on on matrix math or
linear algebra whatever you want to
refer to it as it just depends who's
talking about it but scalars how do they
work well it's pretty simple but also
there's a few little nuances you should
know about so we're just gonna go over
them quickly today okay so let's say we
have a matrix oh oh that's a big block
let's not make it okay hold on second
alrighty say we have a matrix we'll put
it in this form it's got some numbers in
it 7 a 9 and X and I don't know a yes
that's a 9 and a 1 now what a scalar is
is it's a little number right beside it
usually in this area or it could be in
this area and it just tells it how much
to scale the matrix by so if it's a 1
well it's there's always a 1 so it would
just equal the same thing if it's a 2
every element is doubled so this would
equal 14 because 2 times 7 is 14 2 times
9 is gonna be 18 2 times 1 is 2 2 times
X is 2x so there's that you don't do a
bunch of times
and I want to show you another example
so this can be anything give me a 10 or
make it 10 times larger
this is often using modeling to increase
the size of your model you can also
shrink by using something a number
between 0 & 1 so if you use like a 0.5
this will half everything you'll end up
with 3.5 4.5
of course because 7
times point five it's three point five
five times or 0.5 times nine is 0.5 and
so on and of course X will now be x over
2 or X divided by two so there is no
division here if you want to divide you
just gotta use a smaller value something
between 0 and 1 that's pretty much all
there is to scalars so if you ever
putting a scalar on a matrix this is how
it works you can increase it by
something by a number 1 or higher
well higher than 1 of 1 is gonna be the
same thing and you can decrease it or
effectively divide there is really no
divide here in matrix math as we'll find
out the way to scale it down is by
multiplying it by that smaller number
between 0 and 1 alright thanks for
watching see you guys the next episode
and keep it real take care of yourselves